المطبخ التونسي هو جزء من المطبخ
المغربيات واليهوديه ومن ثم العربيه
والتركيه والايطاليه وثقفه اخرى
[موسيقى]
يعرف المطبخ التونسي بترائه بالنشويه
والفواكه والخضروات لحم الذقن هو المفضل
مع استعمال المكثف للدجاج يشتهر ببهاراته
الفريده والمكونات الطازجه التي تدخل في
اعدادي لائحه حافله من الاطباق التي تتاثر
بالمواسم كغيرها من اطباق المتوسط
[موسيقى]
الخبز عنصر الرئيسي في المطبخ التونسي
وتختلف وطرق عمله وتقديمه الثوم وزيت
الزيتون مكونات قلم تغيب عن وجبه اطبق
الاسماك وغلل البحر هي عباره عن حفل بحر
مصغر يزين المواد في كل فصل
القهوه والشايب شعبيه كبيره في تونس قائمه
طويله من الحلويات التقليديه اللذيذه
والمتنوعه وهي رمز قار في الاحتفالات
والاعياد مطبخ لا يستغني عن الشمس
باختصار المطبخ التونسي حاله خاصه غير
ممسوح بها لاحباء الرشاقه والحميه الى
صباح العربيه احلام العبد اللي تونس